-Welcome back.
-Jimmy!
-I'm so happy to see you.
-I love you. I miss you.
-I miss you.
-Since the last time
I talked to you --
You were very nice on Zoom.
-We had a very good time during
COVID together.
-I appreciate that. And during
COVID, you had a baby.
-I did.
-A beautiful baby.
So cute.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I physically didn't have it.
We brought our child
to our home.
And we have an incredible family
now.
It's so incredible.
-Now you have a toddler now.
-Yes, a toddler.
-Yeah, you're a parent.
-I'm a true, full-blown parent.
-Yeah.
-It's the best thing ever.
-I think Cameron Diaz would be
a fantastic parent.
-Well, a lot of my friends
say I'm very nurturing.
-I'll take that.
Is that a compliment?
-That's, like, some of the
feedback that I get often.
It's like,
"You're very nurturing."
-You're like, "What does that
mean exactly?"
Is that a good thing?
-No, I like it.
I like it. I'll take it. Yeah.
-I want to wish you
a happy belated birthday,
by the way, as well.
-Thank you, thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Did you party?
-I'm -- What is it? I'm 50!
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"50 years old!" Sally O'Malley.
-I know. I love it.
It's so great.
-Did you have a party?
-Well, I did have a little,
little party, of course.
If I was having,
like, a big party,
you would have been invited.
-Thank you. Of course.
That's what I was getting at.
Did you have a party?
That's interesting if you did.
-No, no, no. I didn't, I didn't.
-Yeah, of course not. Yeah.
-We just stayed at home.
It's fine.
-Yeah, it was only
like 300 people. That was it.
-It was "really small."
You know, I'm not, like,
a huge birthday person.
But Benj is just -- he loves
a birthday celebration.
You know, he really likes to
celebrate.
Remember the birthday that we
had -- that he --
like, the surprise birthday?
-I was going to say
do you remember that?
'Cause it was a surprise party.
-It was a surprise birthday.
And you guys were all stuck
in the bathroom
for like a half an hour.
-I was in the bathtub.
It was Gwyneth Paltrow's house.
And it was a surprise party
for you and you were late.
-I didn't know
it was a surprise party.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm always late.
-Yeah, yeah.
But we're all stuck
in the bathtub.
We're like, "Why are we hiding
in the bathtub when we could
hide anywhere
in the whole house?"
-Anywhere else.
-But we're all just in this.
It was me and Drew and my wife.
There was like 10 of us in this
bathroom waiting for you.
-I wish -- Somebody has
a picture of it, by the way.
It's, like, really funny.
We should have thought of
something a little bit.
We should've had that picture.
-Yeah, we should've
had that photo.
-You should've had that photo.
-People are very excited
about this.
You're making your return to
acting, buddy.
-I am.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You'll be starring alongside
Jamie Foxx,
who we love, in the Netflix
movie, "Back in Action."
-Yes.
-A perfect title for this.
-I know. Literally.
I was like, "Hey, guys,
so what is the --
What's the title of this?"
And they're like,
"Back in Action."
I was like, "Oh!"
-"Hello! Is this about me?
I'm back."
-I'm really feeling
very connected
to this character already.
-But the thing
on the Internet you did
with Jamie and Tom Brady.
-Yeah.
-It was hilarious
'cause you're like,
"I'm coming out of retirement.
Does anyone have any advice?"
And Jamie's like,
"I have one guy."
And Tom Brady gets on.
He's like, "You want to talk?
I'll give you advice."
It was so good.
So funny. Are you nervous?
Are you excited? Are you both?
-I'm both. You know, it's --
It's a little bit of,
like, muscle memory.
You know what I mean? It's sort
of like I did that for so long,
it's kind of like the process I
kind of just fell back into it.
But it feels a little bit
different.
And I've also made two movies
with Jamie, which is amazing
that I get to make --
The last movie I made was
"Annie" with Jamie.
And so, the first movie back is
this film with Jamie.
So it's, like, amazing.
-He's a blast to --
-He's so great.
He's so easy. He's so
professional. He's so talented.
And just being able to work with
him, it'll be so much fun.
-You get to laugh
and work with him.
-So, I'm nervous about that
because I have to
listen to Jamie because he,
like -- he will go.
And you're just like, "Okay."
He's like a -- you know --
A racehorse. Like, as soon as
you let him out, he's just like,
and you're like...
-No, no. He comes on the show
and I just sit back.
Grab a microphone and he's like
and start doing impressions.
I go, "Just take the show."
Take it and run, buddy.
-I just want to be able to,
like, support him along the way.
-Yeah, me too. I go, "Dude,
just go for it. It's your show."
Jamie Foxx, take over, man.
Yeah, any time.
That's going to be great.
Congrats on that.
-Thank you so much.
-I want to talk about your wine,
Avaline,
because this is a giant hit.
I think the last time we talked
was when you were
launching this.
-Yeah, you were a really
big help for that.
Thank you so much.
-Just me alone.
I ordered -- I drink a lot.
[ Laughter ]
It's all going in here, pal.
Congrats. I'm the guy to go to
when you want to sell wine.
-It's just like all of a sudden,
there's a straw coming in
from the side.
Just across.
-"We're getting another case
delivered to the Fallon
apartment."
I'm like, "Here we go."
[ Laughter ]
But it's a big deal.
And I remember we were talking
about it and you're like,
"Well, it's organic
and we've got to do this.
We're working on it. It's going
to little places at the start."
-No, we went --
Actually we went full blown.
We were like, "Let's put this
in every single grocery store
we possibly can across
the United States
so that everybody can drink it."
-Yeah, that's what it was.
Someone was asking you
to not do that.
-Well, they were telling us
we couldn't, Jimmy.
-Yes, sorry.
-They told us that we couldn't.
-That's exactly right.
And don't tell Cameron Diaz
she can't.
Okay? Let me tell you something!
Don't you dare tell Cameron Diaz
she can't!
She'll prove to you
that she can.
-That's what I'm saying.
I'm from Long Beach, y'all.
You don't tell me --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Long Beach? Long Beach?
-Long Beach. Oh, my God.
In New York City too,
you're getting --
Avaline, this is the label here.
-Yes.
-And a lot of people are saying,
"How do you pronounce Avaline?"
People are saying --
-You did a great job just now.
-I know.
-Yeah.
-I like Avaline.
-Avaline.
-It's Avaline.
-People are like, "What is it?"
-Avaline.
-It's Avaline.
You actually put out a nice
Instagram because people were
saying in your DMs going,
How do you pronounce it?"
-Yeah.
Like, "Av-a-lean."
-Yeah, or "Ava-line."
-"Ava-line."
-No, "Ahva-lean."
-"Ahva-lean."
-Here's your response video.
It's very nice.
-One of the questions we get
often on the Avaline DMs is
"How do you say the name
of your wine?"
It's "ah-va-lean." "Ah-va-lean."
It's Avaline.
It's called Avaline.
♪ Avaline ♪
Avaline, bitches.
-There you go.
That last one snuck in there.
Very happy.
-It was a joyous moment.
-It really was a joyous moment.
Congrats on the success of it.
-Thank you.
-I did say and I will continue
to say I like the labels
because they're all different.
They all tell you exactly
what it tastes like.
-So, you know when you go into a
grocery store and you kind of
know one varietal because you --
that's the one you tasted
and you're kind of like, "I like
the way that tastes.
Well, what does it taste like if
you want something that's
full-bodied or has a little bit
of fruit, a little bit of spice,
or a dry white, crisp white?"
Instead of saying -- trying to
find the varietal that tastes
like that, we just tell you what
it tastes like on the bottle.
-No, that's what makes it great.
-So you can just know and go,
"That's the wine I want."
-So I go in, usually I go,
"Box or glass."
[ Laughter ]
It's where I'm going.
But it says --
You can actually pretend you
know what you're talking about.
"Is this, like, medium to
full-bodied I'm feeling?"
-Yeah, yeah.
-Notes of like red berries and a
little hint of cocoa in this?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Yes, I was getting that
on my palate as well.
-You were getting that --
-Yes.
-Would you like to try a little
here?
-Sure.
So, this is our Cabernet.
-A little Cabernet Sauvignon.
-Yes.
We just launched this
on drinkavaline.com.
And it's our Cabernet.
So, we don't do -- We do
varietals on our website.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Appreciate that.
Cheers.
-And cheers to us.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, gorgeousity.
I love it. Cameron Diaz,
everybody. Avaline.
When we come back, Cameron and I
are going
head-to-head
in a wine scooter race.
Stick around, everybody.